Netflix, the reigning champion of all streaming
sites, is still many people's go-to when looking
for a new film to watch. Whether you want
a classic favorite or a hot new release,
the streaming giant has no shortage of
movies for film aficionados to enjoy.
This holds especially true for horror fans.
For many, Netflix is the best place for horror
this side of Shudder. Netflix often snags
the distribution rights to some remarkable
scary films, giving audiences plenty of
options when they are in search of a fright.
We're not even into October yet, and the
service has already provided some of the most
chilling films of the year already
with the "Fear Street" trilogy and
"Army of the Dead." The latest film to
keep you up at night is 2020's "The Old
Ways" — and the suspenseful film has
audiences on the edge of their seats.
The film follows Cristina Lopez,
a Mexican-American journalist who
returns to her hometown near Veracruz to
research a story on witchcraft. There,
she is kidnapped by a group of locals,
including a bruja, — which means..
Witch, in English —who thinks she’s
possessed by a demon. All the familiar
beats of a classic demon possession movie
are there, but with some sly twists,
the film manages to embed itself within your
mind. You can watch the trailer to see if it's
up your alley as you witness Cristina fighting
for her life — and struggling to know what's real.
Right from the opening scene, you know
you're in for a terrifying time. We get
the chance to see an exorcism in action,
and immediately after that, we see a woman
with a bag over her head. You wind up being
just as confused and terrified as Cristina,
and that's when the big revelation takes place.
Her cousin, Miranda, and some of the townsfolk
want to keep her restrained until they have an
opportunity to remove the demon inside of her.
Cristina may abide by modern sensibilities,
but in this town, they adhere to the old ways.
The movie scored a fairly impressive 100%
Tomatometer rating on Rotten Tomatoes.
Michelle Swope of Dread Central praises the film
for its "wicked practical effects," and how it,
"Uses body horror as a way to represent Cristina's
inner demons and her refusal to deal with them."
Over at The Upcoming, Andrew Murray calls it
"A highly entertaining new
spin on the exorcism genre."
"The Old Ways" is more than just your
average horror film though; the film
explores complex themes such as addiction,
feeling like a stranger in your hometown,
and loss of culture. The movie also highlights
the unshakeable bond of family. In particular,
Kat Hughes of The Hollywood News
remarks on the film's exploration
of the relationship between the captured
Cristina and her estranged cousin, saying,
"Watching these women attempt to reconnect,
especially under extreme conditions,
adds a necessary layer of warmth to what could
be just another heartless and cold horror."
The perfect mix of body horror, exorcism,
family drama, and thrilling suspense,
"The Old Ways" is a must-watch
— now streaming on Netflix.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about
hidden horror gems are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don’t miss a single one.